foreign
19 vaccination is rising and many
vulnerable African communities thanks to
eu-funded who led project
so Africa for those of you who don't
remember
was I think the least vaccinated
continent
um
and it also had a very low excess deaths
very low covered rates and part of that
is presumably attributable to
uh to relatively high vitamin D levels
and some of it I suspect is some of the
lack of excess deaths deaths is
attributable to the lack of vaccine
uptake so now that it's 2023 and even
the Die Hard covidians have largely
stopped taking their boosters
what's a poor pharmaceutical company to
do
well what you do is you get in bed with
the EU and who and so lucky for you that
they'll have you and you go into Africa
because we don't do nefarious things in
Africa do we no so here's a few of the
things that the who has to say the same
month that they're impressing upon the
weird world that salt is the enemy
here's what they're doing in Africa
March again 2023. at the start of 2022
oh I'll just begin at the beginning of
this of the thing covid-19 vaccination
coverage is on the rise and some of
Africa's most fragile humanitarian
settings as a two-year project funded by
the European Union enters its last four
months at the start of 2022 the covid-19
vaccination rate was less than 5 percent
on average in the 16 participating
countries that rate is now closing in on
30 percent the continent's average among
the 14 countries whose data was
available in January
the countries participating are
Burundi Cameroon Central African
Republic Chad Democratic Republican
Republic of the Congo Guinea Liberia
Madagascar not technically Africa but
I'll let that slide Molly Mozambique
Niger Nigeria Somalia South Sudan Sudan
and Tanzania
to achieve those Rising numbers national
health workers trained by who experts
have been administering vaccines in
urban hubs remote Villages Refugee and
displacement camps workplaces public
spaces and elsewhere
we don't wait for the people to come to
the vaccine vaccination sites we go to
the rural areas to allow these
populations to be vaccinated without
having to travel and abandon their work
in the fields which is very precious to
them siddhari rabiu Regional director of
the public of Public Health population
and social Affairs in Marathi Niger
Rashida Ibrahim a nurse at a health
center in
karangaso apologies for the
pronunciation elaborated on that way of
working quote every morning we
vaccinated people against covet 19. when
there's nobody left to vaccinate we get
on the motorbike and go to a village to
vaccinate there also
a few more quotes from this who article
Mozambique has been one of the Project's
success stories nearly two-thirds of the
country's population has been fully
vaccinated among that group is Julieta
Jose I don't know how to pronounce it a
resident of the Malika camp for
internally displaced people
quote I'm very happy about the visit
from the team because some people here
in the community were never vaccinated
she said it's the best way to prevent
Cobin 19. I told everyone I know to come
and get it
said another person
who had uh who was a who was trained to
provide these vaccines I know that I
know that if they all get vaccinated my
community will be free of this bad
disease
so if I may have my screen back
um
there's a lot to say here of course but
one of the things that jumps out at me
is that there's this technique being
done here
which we've seen throughout since since
covid first entered our
our thinking in the public in which you
take someone
who
doesn't know and has no way to know
whether or not the thing that they have
been told is true
covet will kill you you must stay inside
these vaccines are the only thing that
will protect you you must get vaccinated
right so authorities come
in this case who trained authorities and
they come and say
this is what to think in this case these
vaccines are the only thing
that you can do to protect yourself
against a disease which will probably
kill you
I don't know if that's actually what
they say but it's something like that so
the authorities come and they say
they tell you what to think
and then they put a microphone in front
of your face and they say what do you
think
and then you say what you've been told
to think to the people who told you to
think it
and having said that your words are
documented and it's produced in pieces
like this
but that's not data
it's not even anecdote
what that is is propaganda
but we are being
what we are seeing what we are hearing
here is propaganda that is masquerading
as true life stories as what people
believe what people what people on the
ground feel and know that their friends
and their family members need to do this
thing because they know it's true but
they don't know it's true they were told
this by the propagandists and the
propagandists then got them to record
themselves saying it and then produced
it to the rest of the world who then
help with the propagandists campaign
that's all this is It's there's no
evidence here there's there's no new
information here it's propaganda
appearance simple
and it's propaganda completely agree
it's also marketing one has the sense
that this is the marketing department
masquerading as the medical Department
yeah and what they're doing
is
creating
pretexts all the way along it's a little
bit like um
incentivized reviews you ever run across
a product that has great reviews and you
think okay this is the one and you buy
it and then you discover that there's a
mechanism by which they induce people to
leave great reviews and that's the
explanation for why anybody liked the
thing at all right
um it's a lot like that and you know
actually going back to the The Who right
and the the salt story This Is The Hoot
too right I know but
that story also has the marketing
department all over it right because
it gets me when they say you know the
problem is sodium it's the intake of
sodium right no no
you're talking about a molecule right it
is sodium chloride it's not the only
salt you could make with sodium
but the salt that we take in is sodium
chloride that matters sodium on its own
is explosive when combined with water
right and chloride on its own is highly
toxic this salt is a an item that is
very common in our environment that has
its properties that we can engage with
and we can even know how to
conceptualize it based on the hydrogen
bond that links these two things
together and so when they say sodium it
sounds sort of clever and sophisticated
that they would refer to it in this
chemical way right rather than say salt
sodium that sounds very sophisticated
but they've indicted they do also
mention what like non-sodium glutamate
and like there are other things that we
eat that have sodium in it I know but my
point is scientifically speaking it's
not what they mean and the marketing
department yes it's trying to throw lots
of stuff at you that sounds scientific
and the point is the scientists weren't
involved it's like a car commercial in
which the people are driving the thing
on the roads in a way that would violate
the warranty tea and would result in the
burning out of some component but the
engineers were never consulted right
this is its marketing pure and simple
well
it's even worse than that oh no
yeah
um I mean and you know this I fear that
the scientists were involved but the
scientists aren't scientists anymore
scientists are marketers the scientists
are marketers or you know the the kids
who were excited about Discovery and
exploration
um and he went into science for that
reason
quickly came to understand that that's
not the world of modern science and some
of them jumped chip into other things
and some of them stayed in and you know
fought the man as it were in The Who and
you know all the rest and uh most of
unfortunately I think it's most at this
point uh of the people who are
actively doing science in these Realms
right now have at some level accepted
this as what science is either that or
they're living with such constant
cognitive dissonance that I don't
understand how they don't explode
um so I I think that the answer is that
they have forgotten or never knew what
science actually is
and have accepted this piss-poor
replacement that has no chance of
discovering truth or of making the world
better as what science is and that's the
science we're advised to follow not the
actual science yeah and it really it
does raise questions you know who are
they I really want to know and I really
want to know why they do not recognize
that they are in violation of something
this important elevated and Universal
Nuremberg well I mean science and
medicine are related but distinct so
both things are called out in this
document okay right
so
um
I wonder of course about what will
happen
now that there is a mass vaccination
program that is going forward in Africa
excuse me
not that we don't have a long history of
messing with Africa and Africans
but my prediction is that we'll see a
rise in excess deaths excess mortality
and as uh
uh as a result of this Mass vaccination
program and I have to wonder what
they're gonna blame it on there's a lot
of things possible maybe it'll be salt
intake
um
I would also just point out that this
would also fit a long pattern of uh
destroying the control group so that in
the future we are not able to deduce
what actually happened to us yeah um the
idea that there was a continent with a
low vaccination rate and then we might
be able to look at all of the new
pathologies and patterns that emerge and
say interesting that they also appear to
be at a much lower frequency in Africa
so um how diabolical would you have to
be if this was consciously on anyone's
mind the idea that there are patterns of
harm that would be detectable if Africa
functioned as something of a control
group or contained enough people to
compile a retrospective control group
right and you actually decided to arm
them too so that that was impossible
you'd have to be pretty darn diabolical
yes you would
[Music]